today is lakers day at the ravine the
newest laker russell westbrook also
threw the first page one champion
celebrating another on laker day at
dodger stadium david price started
earlier on this home stand two runs over
four and two thirds against the pirates
this is his 11th start for the dodgers
and he's always pitched pretty well he's
not gone particularly deep and so he's
still looking for his first win as a
start nemo takes up and in for ball four
in the midst of a lead off base runner
so the lead off walk and pete alonso
stepping in
he got him swinging one gone here in the
first now javi baez first played
appearance back in the lineup activated
off the injured list today he's played
10 games for the mets and then missed 12
days
and he drives this one out to left field
chasing pollock back it's over his head
and short hops the wall on his way to
third is nimbo he's going to be waved
around the relay throw to the plate by
seeger on a hop not in time
javi baez back in the lineup with an rbi
double to get the mets on the board
early the exactly the kind of hit the
mets have been lacking one scoring
double for bias to bring home nemo with
the first run of the game now jd davis
the batter baez at second eighth pitch
of the at back swinging a line drive
toward the right side to base hit into
right field baez rounds third he's
headed home chris taylor's throw to the
plate not in time baez dives across
safely and the mets have scored two here
in the first jd davis punches a ball
into right field and the mets with back
to back run scoring hits taking a two
nothing lead two out davis goes to
second and that puts a runner in scoring
position for jonathan vr
vr punches one to center it's going to
fall in from base and here's davis
around third trying to score bellinger's
throw to the plate will come up short vr
down to second he arrives safely the
ball gets away he breaks for third
bellinger will put it in his pocket vr
winds up in third base and the mets have
a three nothing lead
a little duck snort to center field off
the bat of vr
he takes second on the throw home as
davis scores right-hander marcus
strowman on the mound strowman's eight
and 12. his era 284 for the year but
when they do get to three or more
stroman is 6-0 and the mets have already
had three
in the first inning today trey turner
seven for 12 in this series and he gets
a fast ball and drills it to left back
goes drury to make the catch on the
warning track for a hard first out and
strowman's got two up two down in the
first as justin turner will back
slider lifted to shallow right center
and back goes pilar to make the catch
side retire three fly ball outs for
strowman after the mets got him the lead
corey seeger will lead off the bottom of
the second against marcus strowman
swinging a missed strike three swung
right through it it's the first
strikeout for marcus roman one out
nobody on will smith will be the banner
that's on the outside corner strowman
painting with the slider to get will
smith and strowman's got back-to-back
strikeouts to start the second and the
dodgers have their first base runner
pollock going to the count and that
snaps off inside for strike three three
strikeouts in the end for stroma baez
leads off the third fires down on
strikes third k for price one gone in
the third
he just challenges them with that
fastball and is able to get that swing
and miss and now brandon jury bounced
back to the mound his first time up a
swing and a miss in a one two three
third first clean inning for david price
so the pitcher david price will now step
in
christ with a base hit the first of the
game for the dodgers
boy david price rakes doesn't he
that's his third hit in his last four
starts 104 miles per hour for david
price top of the order trey turner
rounded to the shortstop vr halfway to
second and
the rs relay not in time so bias with
that quick toss to get the force turner
takes his place at first with two gone
and max muncie coming up and muncie
chases one for strength three mazika
will make the toss down to first
if he needs to and he doesn't because
muncie abandoned his effort to go to
first one away here's seeger hesitates
and deals and seeger goes up the middle
with a knuckling line drive of a base
hit fights it off for the first hit for
a position player today round round
first two gone taylor's walk strowman's
taylor pulls it to third that's off
davis ricochets de baez who throws late
he took the brunt of that ball
that carried off him to baez
who almost threw out taylor taylor winds
up with an infield hit but let's see
about jd and he's going to try and uh
stick it out
and that sets up a moment of truth for
marcus with the tying runs on base cody
bellinger hits one down the line that
drops in for a base hit
throw comes home it is not in time and
bellinger comes through
to get the dodgers on the board
a two out two run single and it's 3-2 in
the four talk about feeding off that
positive energy after that first
half-bat you had a line drive great
slide by chris taylor to avoid the tag
and get the hand on the plate and with
the time run now 90 feet away this makes
another layer to the decision for dave
roberts with david price she elects to
send up billy mckinney as the pinch
hitter
runner goes the throw to second no break
for the plate they've got the run down
going and the tag is made for the third
out so bellinger took off pollock never
left third base and they get bellinger
in the rundown to end the inning
the pinch hitter yeah he did burn the
pinch hitter lead off then on for the
mets in the six jeff mcneil announces
the pinch hitter he drives one to left
center field and that's down from base
hit and it's going to go all the way
back to the wall digging for third is
davis he's going to be held up there
mcneal pulls in at second first pitch
pinch hit double and the mets are in
business second and third nobody out
jonathan vr coming up 2-2
and he does get a strikeout sinking 99
for the first out of the six
now the infield's going to come in with
one out and pillar at the plate the 1-2
pitch is pulled to short seeger's coming
home with it and they've got davis hung
off
mcneil goes to third the smart play
davis tagged out two gone
and graduals on the doorstep of getting
out of this thing patrick mazeka is
going to get put on dave roberts forcing
luis rojas his hand here does he send
roman up there you figure he will
a strike away from getting out of it
unscathed that's bounced back to him he
comes home forced it home in and over
that's at second and third and nobody
out and they do not score marcus is
bounced back nicely after that two run
fourth inning he's retired five in a row
the 3-2 pitch again to smith swinging a
miss strike three that slider up in the
zone but smith strikes out and marcus
strowman pats his mint let's out of yell
as he records strikeout number six no
two out of nobody on now javi baez
two-two coming
and the breaking ball pulled into left
field a base hit for baez tracked down
by pollock baez a hard turn he's going
to try for two and he slides in safely
javi baez with a hustle double
challenging pollock
the throw was wide turner tried to get
back
baez in safely with his second double of
the day
hair on fire indeed on fire for
everybody else that's a single this is a
team that was in dire need of a little
boost of energy javi baez has provided
that energy avi trying to light a fire
for the mets he did it in the first
inning and gets to second here with two
outs and we'll see what jd davis can do
and he lines one toward left field back
goes pollock looking up and it's out of
here
jd davis with a line drive two run homer
bias hustles a double and j.d on the
very next pitch lines a two-run shot his
fifth home run of the year and it's five
to two new york well this is shane
greene about to make his dodger debut 32
year old from florida so the mets have
two men on and here's javi baez who has
been the big story today for the mets
and that one hits baez and now he stares
out at shane green it was a breaking
ball that hit him but back-to-back
hitters plunked by green to load the
bases well it gives the mets a chance to
blow the doors off this game in the
ninth a single and two hit batsman
loading the bases for jd davis
and davis draws a walk and that forces
in a rod
fourth rbi of the day for jd davis as
nimo comes home to scoring at six to two
new york and dave roberts will make the
pitching change and bring in the
left-hander gonzalez to face jeff mcneal
slapped on the ground
backhand flip by turner out at second
safe at first as a run comes home turner
had trouble getting rid of that ball
don't know if he would have had a chance
to turn two had he gotten rid of it
quickly but they forced jd at second for
the second out five run lead for edwin
diaz to protect in the bottom of the
night and now diaz has the dodgers down
to their final out he struck him out and
the ball game is over for only the
second time in the last 10 games the
mets get themselves a victory their
final game of the year against the
dodgers finally get themselves a win
for today's game
for the new york